I'm gonna make his life a lot easier
he's gonna just destroy mine they're
gonna probably be like wow you're not
asking me for ice cream and you actually
want to Netflix and chill okay yeah
maybe they might be a little confused by
that an example of alex ernst tweet just
say something really [ __ ] up and
they're like hey what's up out my tweets
are art alright for URI it's been too
damn long and it's time to get him a
date cheesy pickup lines that's like my
thing I'm gonna fix all your
relationships that would be me I think
pretty much gonna go as hard as you go
on me once I start talking I know alex
is gonna come back and do it the same
for him to trust me with this phone so
I'm leaving work and I'm proud to say I
got you a date I have Eli Stone and I
changed his profile picture to kind of
drag don't know where ureas and check my
Instagram he is having dinner with some
lady and ever seen before in my life
the girls seem to really dig the cheesy
lines I just told all of Alex's fans
that he's releasing a pop solo album
nobody's ever gonna believe him ever
again after this he told all my family
and friends that I won the lottery that
I won eight million dollars so
everyone's like calling my phone I would
go on Facebook and see what he's
messaging people I'm like you know what
he's not doing a bad job I went on his
Bumble account all I asked was Netflix
and chill they were like yeah I'm down I
had no idea how massive his community
was of women I go on Facebook Messenger
names after names after name said how
does he keep up with all this his
roommate sent him a text to wake him up
at 5:00 so I called him at 5:00 yeah and
I told him I wouldn't be able to make
rent this month
she was texting all night and then I
started getting worried it was just
texting all night long so I was done
after the end of the night I was like I
want my phone back this is ridiculous
no absolutely not no but hell no oh yes
again this is my personal space this is
like one of the few private things I
have with my life it was uncomfortable
it was strange I felt dirty it's
exhausting trying to think of ways to in
his life
oh also there's at least like 36 guys on
tinder
we made a series it's coming on November
18 please watch it get it here yeah yeah
you gotta see it it'll be released 2015
November ok